BOOTH.
IONA START WITH WHAT WE
LEARNED.
I'VE SEEN SOME WHO OPPOSED
THIS AND DISMISS IT.
YES HE MAY HAVE BEHAVED BADLY
BUT IT'S NOT IMPEACHABLE.
LET'S WAIT TILL THE ELECTION
TO HASH IT OUT.
OKAY, EXCEPT THAT'S NOT HOW
THIS IS GOING TO GO DOWN.
IT LOOKS LIKE THIS WILL END UP
WITH THE TRIAL IN THE SENATE.
AS WE MOVE TOWARD THAT, I WANT
ANYONE WHO WATCHES THE SHOW TO
BE WELL INFORMED ABOUT THE
DETAILS OF THE ACTUAL EVIDENCE
, NOT THE TALKING POINTS, THE
EVIDENCE.
WE HAD A LOT OF NEW EVIDENCE
THIS WEEK AND I WANT TO TAKE
YOU THROUGH IT.
HERE'S WHAT HASN'T CHANGED.
THIS WEEK WE HAD NEW
CONFIRMATION FROM AN OLD
FRIEND OF THE REAL MOTIVATION
FOR ALL THE.
>> HE KNOWS HE'S AN
ILLEGITIMATE PRESIDENT.
>> HE KNOWS THAT HE'S AN
>> THEY BEEN WANTING TO GET
TRUMP IN 2016.
THEY WANT TO REMOVE THIS
DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED
PRESIDENT BY NONDEMOCRATIC
MEANS, REGARDLESS OF THE
EVIDENCE.
SO HELPFUL OF HILARY TO
CONFIRM THAT THIS WEEKEND SO
MUCH FOR THEIR PIOUS LECTURES
ON DEMOCRACY AND THE RULE OF
LAW.
LAST SUNDAY WE WENT THROUGH
THE IMPEACHMENT CHARGES.
THE FOREIGN MEADOWLAKE CLAIM
IS A JOKE.
IT HAPPENS EVERY DAY IN
WASHINGTON THROUGH FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT LOBBYING.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE UP TO THEIR
NECK IN FOREIGN MODELING.
NANCY PELOSI TOOK MONEY FROM
UKRAINE LOBBYISTS.
THEY HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH IT
WHEN IT SALACIOUS OF THEIR
CAMPAIGN AND JOBS FOR THEIR
BENEFIT WHEN ASKING UKRAINE
FOR DIRT AND WHEN IT'S FUNDING
A DOSSIER TO BRING TRUMP
DOWN.
IN ANY CASE, ELECTED LEADERS
ALWAYS WEAR THEIR GOVERNMENT
HAT AND THAT OF A POLITICIAN.
EVERY CONVERSATION, EVERY
MEETING THERE THINKING ABOUT
POLITICS.
THE IDEA THAT DONALD TRUMP CAN
MAKE AN ABUSE OF POWER IS A
JOKE.
THEY ALL DO IT.
I THOUGHT MYSELF WITH
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND DAVID
CAMERON.
TODAY, THE IMPEACHMENT
FANATICS RECITE DIRT ON THE
PROTOCOL ARRIVAL BUT WITH
UKRAINE AND BIDEN IT'S NOT
JUST ANY RIVAL.
IF HE WAS ASKING THEM TO LOOK
FOR ANDREW YANG WHO WORKED ON
ONE OF HIS STARTUPS THAT WOULD
BE DIFFERENT.
WE WILL LAID OUT FOR YOU IN
DETAIL IN TONIGHT SWAMP
WATCH.
IS THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
AND HIS FAMILY ACTED CORRECTLY
IN ANOTHER COUNTRY.
[INAUDIBLE]
THE REASON THERE SO UP IN ARMS
ABOUT IT IS THAT IT'S EXPOSING
A CENTRAL FEATURE OF THEIR
SWAMPY BUSINESS MODEL.
WHAT'S NOT OKAY IS USING
GOVERNMENT POLICY AND TAXPAYER
DOLLARS TO PUSH FOR AN
INVESTIGATION IF THE
MOTIVATION IS PURELY
POLITICAL.
THE ONLY REALLY SERIOUS
CHARGES THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
DID THAT BY WITHHOLDING
MILITARY AID UNLESS THEY
PROMISE TO INVESTIGATE BIDEN
AND HE DID IT FOR PURELY
POETICAL ENDS.
LAST WEEK I TOLD YOU THERE
WERE THREE REASONS.
TRUMP IS A WELL-KNOWN AID.
ROB PORTLAND BACKED UP HIS
ACCOUNT AND ACCORDING TO THE
NEW YORK TIME, UKRAINIAN
DIDN'T KNOW THE AIDE WAS HELD
UP UNTIL A MONTH AFTER.
HOW CAN THERE BE A QUID PRO
QUO WHEN ONCE I DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT IT.
WE'VE LEARNED MORE ABOUT IT
THIS WEEK FROM SENIOR DIPLOMAT
TEXT MESSAGES.
TURNED OUT IT WAS SEEN BY
STRONG U.S. OFFICIALS AS PART
OF A PURELY POLITICAL QUID PRO
QUO.
HERE'S BILL TAYLOR, ACTING
AMBASSADOR TO UKRAINE AND I
SAT ON THE PHONE I THINK IT'S
CRAZY TO WITHHOLD SECURITY FOR
HELP WITH A POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN.
THE DEMOCRATS THINK THAT'S
THEIR SMOKING GUN.
THE REPLY WAS THIS, I BELIEVE
YOU'RE INCORRECT ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S INTENTIONS.
HE'S BEEN CRYSTAL CLEAR, NO
QUID PRO QUO ANY KIND.
NOW LOOK.
I'M JUST BEING HONEST.
THOSE TAX ON THEIR OWN WITHOUT
CONTEXT SHOOK MY FAITH IN THE
WHITE HOUSE POSITION AND OF
COURSE THE TRUMP HATING MEDIA
WERE ALL OVER IT.
THEY LEFT ME WANTING TO KNOW
TWO THINGS WERE THEY TOLD THE
MILITARY AID WAS BEING HELD UP
AND WHAT WAS THE INTENTION TO
INVESTIGATE BIDEN ON THE
GROUNDS OF CORRUPTION OR
BECAUSE HE WAS A CLINICAL
RIVAL.
NOW, AS LUCK WOULD HAVE IT,
WE'VE GOT MORE EVIDENCE ON
EXACTLY THOSE POINTS.
THE TEXT MESSAGES WAS GIVEN TO
CONGRESS BY KIRK, OUR SPECIAL
ENVOY TO UKRAINE.
HE ALSO GAVE HIM AN 11 PAGE
WITNESS STATEMENT.
SOME CALL THAT STATEMENT
DEVASTATING FOR THE PRESIDENT,
POINTING TO THE FACT THAT THEY
DEBUNKED CLAIMS BY RUDY
GIULIANI ABOUT UKRAINE'S ROLE
AND JOE BIDEN'S ROLE.
IT'S NOT THE WHOLE STORY.
IT'S NOT EVEN THE MAIN STORY.
HIS STATEMENT IS INDEED
DEVASTATING.
BUT NOT TO THE PRESIDENT.
IF YOU READ THE WHOLE THING,
THE STATEMENT IS DEVASTATING
FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
IT PRETTY MUCH EXONERATES THE
PRESIDENT ON THE MAIN
IMPEACHMENT CHARGES.
KURT HAD BEEN INVOLVED IN
EVERY ASPECT OF THE STORY.
HE HAS BEEN DESCRIBED BY TRUMP
CRITICS AS AN HONEST BROKER.
LISTEN TO HIS ACTUAL EVIDENCE
ON PAGE THREE HE SAYS AT NO
TIME WAS I AWARE OF OR TOOK
PART IN AN EFFORT TO URGE
UKRAINE TO INVESTIGATE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN.
FROM THE EXTENSIVE TEXT
MESSAGES I'M PROVIDING WHICH
CONVEY REAL DIALOGUE, VICE
PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS NEVER A
TOPIC OF DISCUSSION.
ON PAGE SIX, DELAYING A
MEETING, A DELAY THAT BASED ON
THE TEXT ALONE, THE MEDIA IS
EVIDENCE OF TRUMP PRESSURING
UKRAINE TO INVESTIGATE BIDEN.
HE SAYS BUT I BELIEVE THE
PRESIDENT LONG-HELD NEGATIVE
VIEW TOWARD UKRAINE WAS
CAUSING HESITATION IN ACTUALLY
SCHEDULING THE MEETING.
NOTHING TO DO WITH
INVESTIGATING BIDEN.
EXACTLY AS HE'S BEEN SAYING.
ON PAGE SEVEN, HE REPORTS ON A
MEETING HE ARRANGED AS RUDY
GIULIANI, AFTER THEY MET THEY
CALL ME TO IT GIVE ME THEIR
IMPRESSIONS.
BOTH WERE POSITIVE.
NEITHER SAID ANYTHING ABOUT
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN.
BASED JUST ON THE TEXT, THEY
HAVE ZEROED IN ON TALK OF THE
STATEMENT THAT THE U.S. SIDE
ONE OF THE UKRAINIANS TO
MAKE.
AGAIN, THIS IS CITED AS
PRESSURE TO INVESTIGATE
BIDEN.
IT WAS GENERIC I CONVEYED THIS
TO THE AMBASSADOR WHO AGREED.
IN HIS VIEW THE STATEMENT
SHOULD INCLUDE.
[INAUDIBLE]
THERE WAS NO MENTION OF VICE
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
THERE WAS A QUID PRO QUO OF
MILITARY AID.
HERE'S WHAT KURT SAID ON PAGE
NINE OF HIS STATEMENT.
THE ISSUE ALSO CAME UP DURING
THE SAME TIME, I DID NOT
PERCEIVE.
FINALLY ON PAGE TEN WHAT HE
WAS TOLD ABOUT THE PHONE CALL
AND PEOPLE WHO WERE ACTUALLY
ON THE CALL.
I RECEIVED THE GENERAL READOUT
AS WELL AS.
[INAUDIBLE]
THEY ALL THOUGHT IT WAS A GOOD
CONGRATULATORY CALL AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP REITERATED,
THE MAN AT THE CENTER OF THIS
DESCRIBED BY TRUMP CRITICS AS
AN HONEST BROKER, SIX TIMES HE
SAID HE SAW NO EVIDENCE OF
EFFORT TO INVESTIGATE HIM AS A
POLITICAL RIVAL OR TO LINK
THAT TO AID IN A QUID PRO
QUO.
THE FACT THAT NO ONE,
LITERALLY NO ONE HAS REPORTED
THIS JUST SHOWS YOU HOW
COMMITTED THE MEDIA ARE TO
THEIR EMPTY TRUMP NARRATIVE.
IT IS ASTONISHING.
THESE PEOPLE ARE DELIBERATELY
MISLEADING YOU.
THEY THEIR CONTEMPT FOR TRUMP
HAS DESTROYED THEIR
PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT.
IN A WEEK, WHEN WE SAW THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE HIT A 50
YEAR LOW, WE WERE REMINDED WHY
AMERICANS CHOSE DONALD TRUMP.
IMMIGRATION BROUGHT UNDER
CONTROL.
JOBS INCREASED.
CHINA CONFRONTED AFTER DECADES
OF SELLOUT AND SURRENDER.
THE DEMOCRAT OBSESSION IS OUT
OF TOUCH AND DECADENT.
PEOPLE WANT SUBSTANCE NOT
SCANDAL.
WE WILL EXPLAIN YOU THE
IMPEACHMENT EVIDENCE FOR HIS
LONG AS THIS GOES ON.
BUT FOR GOD SAKE CAN THE
DEMOCRATS PLEASE JUST GET A
GRIP, AND THIS FASTEN FOCUS ON
HELPING AMERICANS HAVE A
BETTER LIFE.
NOW PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU SHARE